en el vídeo anterior tratamos de
encontrar la pendiente en un punto o la
pendiente de una curva en un punto en
particular y la forma en la que lo
hicimos fue tomar ese punto en la curva
y elegir otro punto que no estuviera muy
alejado de este y dibujar una línea
secante que unirá ambos puntos y
encontrar la pendiente de esa línea
secante así que este es nuestro cambio
en ya que se divide entre el cambio en x
en este caso h es la diferencia en
distancia de el valor en x de mi punto
de interés y del punto que no está muy
alejado de mi punto de interés y
posteriormente lo que dijimos fue bueno
porque no tomamos el límite un conforme
h se aproxima a 0
conforme se reduce esta distancia entre
estos dos puntos y por lo tanto esta
línea va a tener la pendiente que me
interesa en este punto de la función a
esta función le llamamos la derivada de
f o igual a efe prima de x y ahora vamos
a ver si podemos aplicar esta fórmula
con un ejemplo concreto para qué
quede más claro este concepto cómo vamos
a hacer un caso particular permítanme
dibujar una función en concreto vamos a
dibujar nuestro eje de las yes mejor
aquí no quedó más bonito dibujo mi eje
de las x y vamos a decir que mi función
es esta curva
de aquí
esta es la curva x cuadrada
este es mi eje y mi eje x y quiero
conocer la pendiente del punto cuando x
es igual a 3 y cuando me refiero a la
pendiente ustedes pueden imaginarse una
línea tangente qué pasa justamente en
este punto lo voy a dibujar en amarillo
en donde apenas está rozando la curva en
este punto esta va a ser la pendiente y
quiero encontrar cuál es para hacerlo
voy a utilizar la misma técnica que
hicimos la vez pasada y lo vamos a
generalizar para que esto no tengan que
ustedes hacer para cada número así que
vamos a tomar otro punto por acá vamos a
tomar el punto en el que si éste es 3
va a ser 3 + delta x el punto que voy a
tomar una diferencia en x aquí también
la anotación porque en algunos libros se
van a encontrar una h y en otros libros
se van a encontrar la delta x y no nos
hace daño conocer ambos términos lo
primero que tengo que ver es cuál es
este punto de aquí cuáles son sus
coordenadas
es igual a x al cuadrado x en este caso
es 3 por lo que ya va a ser 3 al
cuadrado 3 x 39
esta parte este valor en que es 9 y con
este otro punto vamos a ver cuál es su
valor en ya tengo aquí mi 3 + delta x es
la función y el valor correspondiente en
g
si es igual a equis cuadrada entonces el
valor en lleva a ser tres más delta x al
cuadrado muy bien entonces tengo aquí
este punto en la curva
y vamos a proyectar este valor en el eje
g
y quedamos que este valor es 3 + delta x
al cuadrado y ahora vamos a calcular la
pendiente de esta línea secante con
estos dos puntos
esta que estoy dibujando aquí y vamos a
ampliarlo para que se note mejor estoy
ampliando nada más esta parte de la
función de la curva
aquí estoy poniendo en mi punto de
interés aquí está el otro punto y aquí
está mi línea secante línea secante
y secante y queremos que en este punto
sus coordenadas son 39 y en el punto de
aquí arriba sus coordenadas son 3 +
delta de x que es el valor en x coma 3 +
delta x al cuadrado pero vamos a poner
el valor desarrollado ustedes pueden
hacer la misma operación es el cuadrado
de a más 2 por a por ve más el cuadrado
de ver y si lo sustituimos sería 9 más 2
por 36 por delta x 6 por delta x más
delta x al cuadrado y todo esto es la
coordenada de este segundo punto este es
el valor de x y todo esto que acaba de
desarrollar es el valor en ye así que la
pendiente de esta línea la pendiente de
esta secante va a ser el cambio en g
dividido entre el cambio en x el cambio
en y es igual a el valor en y de este
punto menos el valor en llegue este otro
punto es 9 + 6 delta x + delta x al
cuadrado
todo esto está coordenada en este punto
menos la coordenada de este otro punto
que es el 9 menos 9 es nuestro cambio en
jeff y lo vamos a dividir entre nuestro
cambio en x
nuestro cambio en x va a ser el valor de
x de este primer punto comenzamos con el
mismo punto que usamos arriba para ser
consistentes 3 + delta equis y esto le
restamos el valor en x de este otro
punto que es 3 - 3 vamos a simplificar
esto en el numerador cancelamos este 9
con este menos 9 y en el denominador
cancelamos este 3 con el menos 3 así que
nuestro cambio en x de hecho termina
siendo el delta x lo cual tiene sentido
pues finalmente esto es el cambio la
diferencia entre estos dos puntos en el
eje x
finalmente la pendiente de esta línea
secante se simplifica como 6 por delta x
delta x al cuadrado entre mi cambio en x
vamos simplificar esto aún más dividimos
el numerador entre nuestro cambio en x
vamos a cambiar de color para que sea
más fácil de ver esto en pantalla la
pendiente de mi línea secante
va a ser igual a dividimos numerador
entre denominador esto queda 6 más
delta x al cuadrado entre delta x me
queda delta x
y mi pendiente queda como 6 más el
cambio en x vamos a escribirlo aquí
arriba y nuestra pendiente es igual a 6
+ delta x la pendiente de esta línea de
acá si esta delta x fuera igual a 1
estos valores en x serían 3 y 4 por lo
tanto mi pendiente sería 6 más el valor
de delta x que es 16 más 17 mi pendiente
sería igual a 7 recuerden que
encontramos una fórmula general para
encontrar la pendiente de esta línea
secante ahora lo que queremos hacer es
encontrar la pendiente de este puntito
de aquí
exactamente en este punto y ahora vamos
a ver qué sucede cuando yo tomo el
límite cuando está delta x tiende a cero
es decir que esta diferencia en x se va
reduciendo por ejemplo si estuviera aquí
esta línea secante pasaría por acá y
fuera todavía más chica estaría más o
menos aquí mucho más cerca de nuestro
punto se convertiría en una línea
tangente que es la línea tangente que
estamos buscando para obtener su
pendiente
el límite desde el está x cuando tiende
a 0 de la pendiente de nuestra línea
secante que es 6 + delta x podemos decir
que esto es igual a 6 así que la
pendiente de nuestra línea tangente en
el punto de interés
en este punto de aquí
es igual a 6
otra forma de escribir esto es que fx es
igual a equis cuadrada
qué es la pendiente de la línea tangente
de esta función
efe prima en 3
estoy hablando en el punto 3 va a ser
igual a 6
no he llegado a una fórmula general para
encontrar la pendiente en cualquier
punto de esta curva pero eso lo vamos a
hacer en el siguiente vídeo